all the examples of cell cell signaling
that we've looked at so far have been
cells within an organism but what I want
to do in this video is point out that
you can also have cell cell signaling
between different organisms and even
between different unicellular organisms
and so what we have here these are
pictures of yeast cells yeast are
unicellular eukaryotic organisms which
means they have they have a nucleus and
they are officialy fungi and what you
see happening in this in this picture
right over here it looks like you have a
second East cell budding off of the
first one this happens fundamentally
through mitosis but yeast can actually
reproduce in two different ways it can
reproduce asexually through mitosis like
this but it can also reproduce sexually
and that's where we're going to talk a
little bit about signaling between the
cells and they do this with mating
factors and this is just an interesting
discussion of yeast generally so if you
start with a yeast cell so this is a
yeast cell right over here and this is a
diploid yeast cell so it has its full it
has its full complement of chromosomes
so it's going to have 16 16 pairs 16
pairs of chromosomes or 32 total
chromosomes
that's a diploid so through mitosis it
could split apart and it would do so
like this the the one that buds off for
most for most species of yeast will be
smaller although there's some that kind
of do more even mitosis but through
mitosis you could throw mitosis you
could produce two diploid two diploid
East tails just like this so all of
these characters all of these characters
right over here are diploid and actually
since just a stress that they are
eukaryotes
let me draw a little nuclear membrane in
here but it can also it can also divide
through meiosis so this is mitosis right
over here mitosis right over your help
produce these two but you can also go
through meiosis meiosis and if we go
through meiosis we're going to produce
four cells and what's interesting about
these
is that these will have will come in one
of two varieties and you could view
these as the sex of these East cells so
they can either be in the type-a variety
so let's make these two type a so that's
a type a that's a type A right there or
they could be in the type alpha variety
so this is a reduce in a different color
so this is a type alpha and this is
another type alpha and all four of these
are going to come through meiosis from
this original diploid cell and since we
went through meiosis each of these are
going to be haploid so these are all
going to be haploid so this is going to
be 16 chromosomes total 16 chromosomes
chromosomes each of them so they're all
going to be they're all going to be
haploid and in fact each of these can
some degree live a life of their own and
continue to reproduce through mitosis
that's worth pointing out that's
interesting you normally wouldn't
associate sex cells if we think about
humans you wouldn't associate you
wouldn't think that sperm cells would be
able to replicate on their own or egg
cells would be able to replicate on
their own but in the case of yeast they
actually can so this this type a cell
could turn into through mitosis it could
turn into to type a cell's so this is
just all interesting background mitosis
so even the products of meiosis can then
my toast themselves with this if that's
all interesting this is all the setup to
think about how they actually signal
because these these haploid cells that
are produced as a byproduct of meiosis
these are these right over here they all
came from the original ancestor which is
actually fairly typical when we're
talking about reproducing and kind of
pseudo sexually reproducing yeast cells
they don't have to the may be one of the
type alphas came from another ancestor
but what happens is they each release
what's called mating factors or you can
consider them to be mating pheromones so
this type a right over here it's going
to produce and it's going to produce the
type a mating factors and it's going to
release them into the space around it so
it's releasing the
type a mating factors and then the
alphas are going to release the type
alpha mating factors so I'll do that in
this drawer in just brown color so
they're going to release the type alpha
mating factors and what happens is each
type has receptors for the other types
factors so so this the type a is going
to have receptors for the type alpha for
the type alpha it's going to be in all
over the outside of the cell and the
type alpha is going to have type
receptors for the type a receptors I'm
going to that an orange
it's going to have receptors for the
type a let me just draw it like that
that's not exactly what they look like
or actually nowhere close to what they
look like but it gives you a sense of
things it gives you a sense of things
and as through these receptors it starts
bonding a lot of say we're on the Alpha
cell right over here it starts bonding
to a lot of these these mating
pheromones these mating factors then the
yeast cell itself it doesn't move but it
starts growing in that direction it
starts growing in the direction where it
says hey I'm sensing a lot of this
mating factor so it starts growing in in
this direction it starts doing something
like that
and the corresponding thing is going to
happen for the type a cell it's going to
have the Alpha factors attached on to it
and because of that says okay I'm
sensing and once again the the the
factor is the ligand it attaches to the
receptor that's the sensing part then
you have signal transduction and it's
actually a it's not too dissimilar from
the map K the the the map K transduction
pathway that we talked about in other
videos and then the response to cell has
is once again to start growing in the
direction of where it fight where it
seems that these mating factors are
coming from and these this kind of
elongation these outgrowths of these
haploid yeast cells they're actually
called schmooze so that right there that
is a shmoo and you might say where did
that come from what came from this
character right over here which was a
cartoon character in the in in the
middle 20th century and I'll you know if
you were well it well it will so avoid
any
snickering and over the course of this
video but that's what it looks like and
as they grow to each other
that actually allows them to join
together and form another diploid
another diploid yeast cell so this
process were to continue if this process
were to continue these two schmooze will
join together and the the genetic makeup
joins together and so we could get
another diploid cell and now this
diploid cell is going to have a kind of
new new combination of DNA so it could
benefit from some of the variation of
sexual sexual reproduction this is
diploid although for yeast cells they're
like studying it because it's not clear
that these are necessarily coming from a
separate gene pools these actually could
have the same ancestor molecule so it is
a bit of an open question in biology of
why do they have you know this type of
sexual reproduction especially when
they're coming from you know when these
are centrally sibling cells as the
byproduct of meiosis but anyway the
whole point of this is one to appreciate
kind of these fascinating things that
are happening even at the level of yeast
cells and that you do have cell cell
signalling not just within an organism
but across organisms especially it or
even unicellular organisms